all right so this is a remake that is a
movie that is a movie that's an epic of
an old time when things should have been
more epic but in the end it's always
worked out for everybody right mm-hmm
Ben Hur so Ben Hur is a remake of Ben
Hur ultimately it's the story of two
brothers what it's ultimately the kind
of the story of Moses but not in Egypt
once Roman once Jewish ultimately Toby
Kebbell plays the Roman one becomes a
Roman soldier falsely accuses his
adopted brother actually he's the
adoptive brother point is they're
brothers also he accuses him of treason
and ultimately just screws his life and
so it's a revenge tale I'm gonna be
honest with you guys this movie the
first half an hour of it was a little
wonky for me I just it jumps a lot of
time very quickly you feel like this
movie probably should have been a
three-hour epic but it was sliced down
to two hours totally get it because
three hours of this probably would start
to grind my gears but I was entertained
at a point he gets sold into slavery
this movie picked the up and I was
having fun with this one seriously I was
just looking around like this became a
different movie the ship scene is the
coolest scene in the movie the end has a
chariot race of its spoil you guys know
that there's a chariot race and Ben Hur
that's the point it was entertaining as
hell it was cool it was exciting Toby
Kebbell I thought was great Toby Kebbell
is one of those up-and-comer so it's
like Toby cabals better than a lot of
the movies Toby Kebbell is in Jack
Huston played Ben Hur I thought he was
fine like both of these guys did a fine
job in the roles they committed one who
does not commit as Morgan Freeman Morgan
Freeman's in this movie Morgan Freeman
the entire time as his look on his face
like long as my paychecks in the mail
dude does not give a he's African
they called him African he's not African
he gives that man he so when you
see the tension of these two brothers
building up you really feel for Toby
Kebbell where he's like I'm in a bad
position uh my military is calling me to
do something that I don't necessarily
want to do but I have to do it and so
that starts him down a path that in the
end makes these two just bitter enemies
and I thought that was done well enough
for me to enjoy the movie on for a lot
of the movie I was on the razor's edge
man I was like I'm probably going to
give this movie a good time if you're
drunk but it does have enjoyment in it
there are a couple of cool scenes all
right this is a spoiler warning for you
guys don't even give a that's right
don't give a I'm spoiling the
ending for you right now I have to tell
you about the ending because I can't
just be like yeah the ending sucked I
need to tell you why I have to set it up
alright so been hers mother and sister
are both they're not dead they're in a
leper colony and life is and so now
he's like oh I really want revenge and
actually screwed my family's life up so
the ending is already dragging on
because Jesus gets crucified early
historically these two events are
happening in the same time so these two
kind of cross paths a couple times Jesus
gets crucified just dragging on dragging
on dragging on you're like all right
it's just dragging on now come on you
can end and then I swear on my life
after Jesus dies rain comes out of the
sky and it's magical rain that cares
their leprosy and then her and his
brother talk because his brother's not
dead he just lost his leg and their look
he's like I hate your guts I'm gonna
kill you if you take one step closer and
then they hug and he lays down the sword
and then the people who got cured from
magic Jesus reign from leprosy they all
get together with Toby Kebbell straight
up ruin their life doesn't doesn't
matter whatever is happening now does it
change the fact that these two ladies
have been in a leper colony straight up
in what will be hell on earth for a few
years now they hug they smile Morgan
Freeman's voice over in no African voice
or twang or accent whatsoever is
happening and the magic rain and
everyone loved each other and then they
ride off into the sunset and then it
fades to white well this cheesy ass
music starts playing that's the end of
Ben Hur mmm this is like if you're
having an okay sexual experience it's
not bad it's not good but you know it's
fine and then I'm gonna use like the guy
being a dick innocent health it's like
if the guy then says to the girl right
before the really ok sexual experience
is coming to an end he just says your
mother's way better than this and then
just ruins the entire experience like oh
my why that's the ending of this movie
the ending of this movie is like in the
DVD special features how they show you
that alternate ending and you're like oh
okay is much better call to scrap that
ending and make the better ending that
we actually saw in the movie know this
ending that's actually in this movie is
the DVD ending that should have been cut
but wasn't cut this thing completely
ruins the entire thing this ending is
cheese on a scale I've rarely
scene in a movie that actually was
starting to win me over throughout guys
in the end Ben Hur was alright I was
getting into it I like the brother
dynamic I like the revenge dynamic
enough it wasn't winning me over
entirely but I could have told you that
there was enjoyment in this movie and
there still is enjoyment in this movie
has completely eclipsed and scrapped the
ending of this film detrimental II
destroyed everything I had experienced
that I found enjoyable that happened
leading up to it it's not but
I'm not gonna remember this movie in
t-minus one day ya already forgot
except that ending that's gonna
stick with me for a while but guys so
Ben Hur have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's the best remake
you have seen ever whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know or worse ending either/or and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more